okay hey everyone it's Michael Volos
from order flows.com here and this is
the orderflows market analysis for uh
Wednesday May 17
2017 and what a day it was the DOW was
down about
1.8% which gave it its largest daily
decline in in about 7 or eight months
and really what caused it is all this uh
Trump Comey garbage that's going on in
the media you know like literally a war
then you know some Republicans are
joining in saying you know this could be
an impeachable offense blah blah blah
it's just a bunch a [__] if you ask
me but really what it's doing is it's
causing uncertainty in the market
uncertainty that um you know that this
drama as you will I mean this is really
a
drama to me it's more of a TV drama but
it's going to distract and slow down the
Trump administration's you know stimulus
plans and you know with that you know
they're not going to be able to roll out
you know the the things that they wanted
to do this you know this year I think
you know tax uh anything on the tax
front will come out next year so it's
just really slowing down um what the
administration was planning to do this
this year and you know people S&P sold
off the bonds big rally
and you know dollar Index uh you know
dollar Index suffered it was also down
again um you know almost not 1% but
pretty uh pretty close I think was like
6 or 7% and
oil we did have a draw um again it was I
think six straight draws in the weekly
oil
inventories and you know we did test
resistance at 49 bucks but um really you
know today you know the main focus was
in the equities markets so there were
some interesting things in the bonds and
the currencies in orderflow but uh you
know we'll jump in with the with the um
equities now again the tools use in this
presentation the orderflows trader and
the Delta scalper the orderflows trader
is the footprint chart Delta scalper
it's one of my
indicators that we use for uh just
analyzing the delta in orderflow just to
you know sort of make it a bit easier
take a little bit off our our brain you
know when when you trade with orderflow
it's really best to use your brain not
automate everything but you know some
things some types of analysis can be
programmed you know just to sort of
point it out to you it's not saying you
know Red Light Green Light you know take
everything in context you know people
say that's a cop I'll take things in
context well you know that's what's
going to separate you from the alos is
that you can put things in context alos
don't necessarily put things in context
you know Everyone likes to be sort of
like a a robot and think you know if I
could um take out all the emotion take
out whatever thought process out of out
of trading then you know then I'm going
to be successful no that that's that's
not the case you know
yes there are examples of you know
people fully automated making a lot of
money in the markets but really the best
Traders are the ones that use the best
the computer that's sitting on their
shoulders their brain um you know and
part of the reason why you know Traders
fail is because you know they sort of
come in with this robotic sense like um
everything has to make sense in the
market you know it has to all line up
perfectly um you know it's like coding
right when you code something everything
has to be correct you could you could
miss one carriage return and it's going
to throw the whole program off it's not
going to work and you know for some
people that's how they approach trading
whereas you know things don't line up
you know everything lines up perfectly
but they forgot the carriage return oh I
can't trade anymore I can't make money
because of this one thing well no you
know trading is not an exact science you
know if it was then there'd be no
markets you know everyone would have it
all figured out and there'd be no money
to be made in the markets but anyway I
digress
um brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation of buy or sell
a Futures contractor make any other type
of investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results again you
know that said that you know my results
you know I've been involved in the
Futures markets trading the Futures
markets since the early '90s
mid90s it's over 20 years so you know my
results is going to be different than
someone that's been trading for a year
I'm going to see things to me that just
stand out that you know maybe other
people can't see because they're not
familiar with you know reading the order
flow or haven't looked at order flow
long enough to really understand some of
those these little things but that's why
I make these videos is to help you know
educate people that you know don't pick
get up you know the first few times that
they look at a chart you know I I just
want to point things out that's really
what these videos are um you know that
to educate people that you know
orderflow is is a great tool for trading
so
snps again you know it started out
really early you know the big selloff
during the Asian session just you know
right on the reopen just down down down
we did get a little bit of a bounce um
you know coming into the European
session or not coming into but during
the European session and then another
bounce right uh during the cash right
before the cash open 10 805 Chicago
time and we get this move okay and you
know there's some interesting things
happening here you know right after the
cash open that's cluing you that this
selloff can start to I say going start
can continue rather um you know honestly
though you know right after the cash
open we did get some buying come in here
um off this low you know it was a low
from um 76 we did rally all the way up
to 83 and 3/4 before the selling came
back in and and what's telling is you
know you see this Delta the Delta's 1
1139 3200
4,000 but this bar here this bar was was
key in picking up that you know the
selling is going to continue before it
sold off into the new lows and what's so
obvious about it again you know coming
back down to Delta I talk about Delta a
lot why because it's very important it's
important piece of information
that 95% of the Traders probably more
don't even look at don't even I say 95%
probably don't even know what it is and
98% don't even look at it but what it
tells you is then buying and selling in
a
bar Max
Delta is the strongest the buying was
you know when someone buys the offer
plus one if someone sells into the bid
that's a negative Delta of minus one and
so you have you know you keep track of
it you know $139 means this bar finished
with a net Delta of 1139 so there's more
aggressive buying now there's always
there's never going to be more buyers
and sellers what we're going to have is
more aggressive sellers or aggressive
buyers okay and what that means what's
an aggressive buyer well someone that
buys at the market basically lifts the
offer or hits the
bid that's being aggressive if you're
sitting on the bid you know what in the
market to come to you you're being
passive so you know when you have a
Delta of 1139 means you have net
aggressive
buyers
1,139 over net sellers so max Delta
is what the most aggressive buyers
number was in the bar so 1571 mind Delta
is the most um aggressive sellers in the
bar 1115 and you it's important to watch
it again you don't have to again you
know it's not order flow is not
something you be living and dying with
every tick by but you know you could
sort of sit back and you can see how
it's developing and you can see here
while the headline Delta number is
increasing as well as the max Delta but
you watch when you get up to this this
swing high up here off the low so you
got Delta of 1139 3271
4528 and the max the Delta is increasing
then you get to this bar it's minus 578
and again you know if you're not looking
at Max Delta or Min Delta you're just
thinking oh you know um sellers were
moderately in control on this bar but
not really if you watch the max Delta
1571 3298
4536 okay 4536 and 4528 which is the Min
the final Delta that's pretty close 3298
3271 that's pretty
close this one the Delta 1571 uh 1139
yeah it's close you it's not as close as
these other twos you know talking about
you know 10 or 20 contracts but still
relatively close but notice how it's
increasing even from this low it's gone
from 52 1066 1571 3298 4536 and here you
got
5278 so this is actually your strongest
um max Delta in this sequence you know
in this rally
but something changed here something
changed the perception in the market
that you know we should be Buy here for
the market to be recovering and go back
up has changed and all of a sudden
sellers are coming in you end up with
the bar final Delta at - 578 so you know
imagine it went from plus 5000 to- 578
so it went from plus 5,000 back down to
zero so you had sellers come in
5,278 and then additional sellers come
in to turn it negative so this was very
important to me that you know this
Market can sell off
and then in the next
bar you got the Delta scalper given a
sell here you know you got a nice strong
Delta minus 7,000 but this one was key
here this bar was key and you know it's
just confirmed in the next bar you do
have a ratio as well um but again you
know maybe if you're not convinced in
this bar that you know sellers are
coming in boom when you see this Delta
scalper kick in you know turn off the
lights it's it's time to go to bed here
and what happens is the market sells off
sells off get down to a new low you know
you sell off from you know the 70 you
know the 80 area down into the 72 area
get a little bit of a bounce you know
here I thought maybe the market could
maybe get a little bit of a rally you
got a nice strong Delta coming in got
some buying coming in off the low you
got the Delta scalper but it comes right
back down with a bearish uh Del a
bearish ratio pointy control up near the
top then you just go sideways
unfortunately make some new lows and
again you know trying to pick a low on
on a day like today I
mean I hate to talk about you know
feelings in the market but if if you
didn't feel that this Market was um
coming off today you got to practice
your emotions on on the market it's just
a lot of downward pressure um it just it
just felt that way there a lot of
negative news nothing positive coming
out
anywhere and you know selling's going to
come in waves on days like that you can
see it comes down bounces up a little
bit comes down bounces up a little
bit you know selling picks up
again again you got you know again if
you're just trying to trade divergences
you're going to get your head whacked
your head handed to you Divergence that
failed Divergence that failed yeah sure
you did rally up a couple ticks couple
points
here I'm sorry still got this cough did
rally up a couple
points down here you do get the the
Delta scalper given another nice buy did
rally again um from you what is that 68
and a half all the way up to 73 and a
half or and then more but
um you know it's just one of those
things you got to be careful you know
trying to pick a low and you know I'm
not trying to pick lows but if something
in the order flow is telling me
something that hey you know what it's
shifting now from a supply driven Market
to a demand driven market then I'm going
to be interested you know Supply is
coming in all a sudden demand is coming
in that's what the Delta scalper does
and it picks this picks this low here
you know we do get a nice rally up
eventually come back down you you get
all the way up here to 75 do come back
down more negative stuff you know
Divergence with the ratio this one just
went sideways on you another failed
another failed Divergence into new lows
later in the day um you got this new low
here this is the another Divergence
you've got the the um price rejector
there given a Buy Signal it does bounce
up a little bit again I say a little bit
you know this the way this Market is
moving a little bit is is Five Points
which is quite decent you know from 61
and a half all the way to 66 and a half
um start working back down going into
the cash close more selling coming in
here um again you hit the low again um
just at Cash close got the Delta scalper
given a buy short live uh bump up um in
in the evening session we're up a bit
right now but you know that that's today
again I'm not looking to to buy it here
and hold it all the way you know going
into the Asian session so you know that
was it for the snps um you know there
was there was some interesting things I
me the most interesting thing you know
was that one early at uh 8:45 here that
you could have sensed the market was
going to go lower now would you have
sold it here and held it all day you
know honestly held it from uh 81 and and
took it all the way down into the 60s
probably not you know but you just you
know catching it here at 80 you know
immediately down to you know into the
70s you know that's your day right there
you know you don't need to be trading
the rest of the day and and struggling
with the market you know if you could
just make a quick you know getting short
here at 2380 covering it down here at at
7374 you know that's six ticks you know
maybe you you'd catch another trade or
two later in the day it's Happy Days you
know it's not like oh I got to sell this
high and buy it down here and scalp this
and scalp that no you know if if you can
take out points out of the market right
people always are I I see you know a lot
of people always trying to scalp for
ticks you know I two ticks here three
ticks there yeah that's all well and
good but what would you rather get you
rather get ticks or points and if you
get a move early of you know six points
seven points then you don't need to be
[__] around you know trying to get a
couple ticks here a couple ticks
there um the next one I'll talk about is
bonds uh bonds had a monster day as
would be expected with such a big big
sharp selloff in the snps so bonds you
know honestly had been going sideways
for most of the European session we did
have a rally during the Asian session
when S&P started tanking then we went
sideways until about
7:00 you know we had made a new high hit
the highs a couple times made a new high
sold off down into this area here at 702
Delta scalper given a
buy got a Z print here zero print is
this zero means you got a zero in the
towards the bottom of the bar which
honestly to me is is a bearish uh
bullish signal when it's on the green
bar if it was on a red bar it' be
bearish and then you start seeing price
rejection in the next bar with um you
know with the ratio here 303 but the
Delta Scupper right here you know
152 you know 02 0304 you know you can be
buying it somewhere in here in the next
bar
152 you know 06 07 05 and and it just
shoots straight up like a [__]
look look at that boom boom boom
straight up I I was talking about this
in the room I said you know really the
move to time to catch it was down here
this was before the room
opened you know straight up you hit this
high up here around 8:00 and you're just
sort of plateau but you I mean look at
that if you could have got in
15025 up to where you get your first
sort of negative sign you know this
Divergence this price
rejector again that's your entire day
right there you know people don't think
that hey I just made um 20 ticks on a
trade I'm going to keep trading yeah you
can okay you could be walking you know
the famous quote from the movie Let It
Ride I I'm walking around I could be
walking around lucky and not even know
it yes you can continue or you you got
to make a choice hey I just made some
money yeah you can stop there's nothing
wrong with you know quitting while
you're ahead and I know sometimes people
press it and they try to get fancy and
then they end up plus 20 ticks early in
the morning end up the day at plus two
ticks and give it all back I mean it
really depends on you that goes down to
your own Trading psychology um but you
know if you're looking for other signs
there's no sign up here necessarily to
be getting
short instead you're seeing you know all
bullish ratios bullish ratios bullish
ratios Delta scalper again kicking off
another buy and again it's Off to the
Races
again you you come up here from
2830 you s you hit this level up here at
06 and you just sort of bounce off a
little bit doesn't go against you and it
just picks up again you got the Delta
surge giving another buy you got some
nice buying imbalances there it's just
sort of hanging around here before it
really picks up again still no reason to
be selling up here you know you do have
these divergences but that's it you know
a Divergence by itself to me is not
necessarily enough reason to be selling
it and it just picks up again and just
keeps you know Off to the Races boom
boom boom new highs new highs you get up
here okay it's a little bit trickier
sorry I drink something there um yeah
this bar we got a ratio
okay but you know be careful just you
know again you just you had a move
almost you know from
1522 all the way up to 15324 and you get
a single thing up here saying hey get
short you better be very selective and
taking it um said you know you just have
a monster move and then you get
something that says uh you know possible
short do you take it yeah you know be
careful because we can still go higher
um Point control up near the top but
honestly I find this bar to be a bit
bearish you know I do like this buying
here you know this imbalance you know as
you're going into the high I do like
that when I say I like it I like it as a
negative sign but it comes right back up
here with um you know a bullish ratio
and continued buying we do make a new
high here you got a high up here
Divergence and you know we do come off
but you know again at this time it's
2:00 in the afternoon are are you really
going to get much out of a trade after
2:00 generally no um and you just sort
of drift a little bit lower again I'm
not I'm not saying you could have
shorted this you do have the Divergence
with the ratio
afterwards and it just sort of hangs
around it does go lower in the European
session but you know honestly by 2:00
you should be done trading the bonds for
the day that's that's the like The
Unofficial cash close for the bonds is
2:00 Chicago time when it's 3:00 New
York
time now crude oil crude oil was
interesting there was some interesting
things in the crude this morning which
uh I'll go
over um where was it here I think it was
this this High
here this is about 5:30 in the morning
again you're coming up to the high look
what do you got you got decreasing Delta
786 523 70 at your high of the day your
strongest negative Delta okay you also
have a ratio you have a Divergence you
have this buying imbalance up at the top
which I and then it's followed up with a
selling imbalance on the way back down
but really what's the takeaway is this
Delta look at this minus 400 it's your
strongest negative Delta of the
morning and is that important yeah it's
important it's recurring at your high of
the day so it's telling you selling is
coming in at this high of the day if
you're not convinced next Bar Green
Point of control same level still
negative Delta then this next bar red
negative Delta Point control lower
now so it's starting to go lower Point
controls are going lower and we get a
little bit of a move off again you know
saying if you're not convinced that this
is your high and you're getting short in
this bar you know 48 92
9394 trades down below 80 so you know
there's good 15 ticks to be had there um
you sort of drift around you get up to
this High here around 820 this I thought
was interesting as well got a ratio with
the Divergence you have this buying and
balance here to me this just looks like
someone sweeping the book and trying to
trigger some stops up here near the
highs you get up to here at high
Divergence and a
ratio it just sort of comes off a little
bit goes sideways before the selling
comes in but again you know that's
you're running up into the inventory
number at 9:30 which as you can see
comes out volume is just extremely thin
at that time puts in a nice rally
afterwards up to uh yeah what was that
high 49 something
4950 um you get up here near the
high you have a Divergence does come off
a little bit test it get within a couple
of ticks we trade back up to this point
of control from
earlier um you know sideways you start
getting some you know you get a selling
imbalance in there we come back we test
it before you know coming off a little
bit you did get the Delta scalper giv a
buy here we do pop up a bit um but
mostly just going sideways
here
there's whatever you get is sort of
shortlived in this market
today can't remember if there's anything
else in here really this is the price
rejector that didn't work out um and
it's where we are right now I'm back
down around 49 bucks bucks um was where
we
reopened the uh Japanese Yen I think it
was a Japanese Yen I don't know it was
strange my euro currency charts did not
work at all thanks ninja Trader I
couldn't get the euro currency chart
open today but um but
anyway what was it is it I think it was
the Yen let see if I can find my Yen
chart yeah
Yen was quite interesting as well um
Yen's a decent contract usually I prefer
the euro currency but yeah the yen is
also a nice contract to be trading so
you know here you're coming up boom you
get up here to this swing
High okay well earlier you had the Delta
scalper it just sort of went sideways on
you didn't work out here you got
the um P control right the high you got
a ratio again I would find that bearish
and it just comes right back on you um
goes you know that that would have
stopped you off but it just goes a
little bit higher then you get up here
at this high and I thought this high was
very important point of control right at
the top you got buying and balance
buying and buying you know a bunch of
buying and balances at the top of the
bar selling and balances inside um you
know you got a ratio as well and I just
found this bar to be a lot more bearish
than this bar so you know while I still
would have bid on this bar this bar
definitely you know i'
be you know biting and taking as much as
I can out of it um because you know you
got aggressive buyers coming into these
new highs they're looking to break it
out they're looking to come in and push
the market
higher and they can't all of a sudden
now all these people that are buying up
here what are they doing they're
realizing they can't they got to start
selling it now again this has come down
to you know your personal preference on
setting imbalance uh thresholds okay if
you would just want to see every
imbalance okay like 9 against zero
that's an imbalance of you know more
than 400% you know more of 4 to one now
usually I prefer to set it at a a
minimum of 50 meaning there's got to be
at least 50 contracts traded so 16
against 69 would show up 8 against 39
would not show up on on lesser traded
contracts you know like Japanese Yen
British pound you know contracts like
that I set it at at one because I just
want to see every imbalance and make you
know the own my own decision
because if you set it at 50 a lot of
these imbalances you know 4 against 48
will not show up 24 against 5 will not
show up 7 against 30 will not show up 20
against two will not show up if you have
it set at 50 it would just be you know
the 23 against 115 the 16 against 69 um
you know 29 against 129 the bigger one
you know anything above 50 would show up
so again you know it's it's up to you
how you want to set your
imbalance volume threshold um said on on
contracts don't don't trade trade a lot
are not as much as you know say bonds or
5 years or snps you know you're not
going to have a problem setting it at 50
it would I very rarely do you get levels
at a bar that's less than 50 contracts
but on lesser traded contracts you might
want to adjust it but this so This High
you I can see all these imbalances you
know on the way up here but you
something's changed in this bar you know
I still got the positive Delta though
but watch how it sells off
and again you know if you're not
convinced that this is going to be your
swing High watch what's happening with
the Delta it's getting weaker on the way
up at your high even though it's not
negative Delta it's still it's weak
weakening 200 10039 101 47 here 154 here
you get the Delta surge kicking off a
little bit off the
high and you know we just you know we
trade lower you know all the way down to
uh 89 o excuse me you know that's and
that's a move from you know
8920 we do get the
Delta scalper given a buy here and what
do you do you go back up you go back up
make new highs you know
so while while you know people say well
you only show the winning trades on the
Delta scaler no you know I showed you
this trade here there was a trade here
you know this one didn't work out so
sometimes it it doesn't work out the way
you like but you know when it does work
out sometimes it's very beautiful here's
a Delta scalper buy talking from the
8908 8909 level all the way up to new
highs new highs new highs new highs all
the way up until here you know
8950 another buy here you know it's up
to you if you want to take this you
should have been long already from
earlier at this area up here there's no
reason to be getting out of the
trade get a high up here ratio with
Divergence really this is your first
reason to be selling and this is around
the 8970 area twoo controls right at the
same level as well watch how the next
bar is going to come in again you know
if you're not convinced that this is a
high wa for the confirmation of the next
bar that's all you got to do no one's
putting a gun to your head say make a
trade now you know you have a potential
High you got a high of the day pick you
know is this going to you're going to
sell it or not you know no no one's
doing that but you know you could sit
there and you can watch what's happening
in the order flow you see oh you point
controls right around the same level put
in some volume let's see how the next
bar comes in point of control clearly
lower than these two point of controls
that's a sign that the market can sell
off a bit and you do you sell off from
you know say again if you're not
convinced that this is your high in the
next bar you should be convinced and
then the third bar you know you're
getting short
896 5ish area and you you know it trades
lower all the way down to you know below
55 before you see some supportive volume
come in here this is a dogee bar with
the um Delta scalper kicking off again
I'm not a fan of dogee bars taking any
sort of signal on
dois again you get another high with the
Divergence and a ratio and you get a
little bit of a selloff wasn't the
greatest sell off um Delta scalper gave
a buy just sort of went nowhere on you
before it stopped you out
um you know here you got single print
for what it's worth do rally
up yeah yeah you got a ratio you had
zero print here the Divergence didn't
work out then you get another ratio with
the Divergence up
here followed up with another ratio
right afterwards and you get a nice a
nice sell off again from you know this
89 or
9,000 area
more or less all the way down to uh you
know it just sold off quite nicely down
to 89 um 80s for circling back up
towards your highs you got Delta scalper
giving a sell here this one didn't work
out then you get another one coming in
right here um a few bars later which
gave you a decent one decent uh a decent
little trade again it's a Delta
scalper I showed you some big moves that
happened today with the delta scalper
but it's called the Delta scalper for a
reason for me it's more of a short-term
trading thing than a long-term trading
um clue so but I know people that they
use it they Trail their stops you know
if there's no reason to be getting out
then they won't get out um you can Trail
your stop however you
like so you know that was that was
basically it today I'll say basically it
there's a lot of other markets I I've
already been talking for about 30
minutes
but you you're seeing a lot of things
happen in the markets today I show well
I didn't show you soybeans I'll just
show you soybeans there really wasn't
much happening in the soybeans and all
honesty you didn't even need to look at
the beans today because there was just
so much other stuff happening in the
other
markets um going back you know 8:30 to
reopen yeah you know give it a few
minutes to settle down people are going
to say oh you're copping out because you
know there's this this failed that
failed no it's the reopen and
let the opening settle down give it a
few minutes I I prefer five
minutes in the soybeans for it to settle
any Market you know Cash open in the
snps I like I won't take very rarely do
I take any trades in the first five
minutes and beans you know on the reopen
at 8:30 there's really no reason to be
taking any trades for the first five
minutes but again you is there any
really any sign any any good trading
opportunities in the bean say not really
not really we've been we're sort of in
this range for you know most of the day
we do make a new low here um you don't
get anything any any reason to be buying
it so that was that was it then we came
in um you know a bit lower in the
evening session some strong
selling a lot matched up there at 972
contracts so anyway thanks for watching
this again you know I'll be doing a
webinar Thursday afternoon
1:45 um you should come in and join um
I'll put the link in the description
below and you know let's just listen to
what I got to say it should be
interesting but again you know if you
can't attend the webinar sign up for it
at least you'll be on the distribution
list for the replays when they come out
you know you don't need to email me
saying hey can I get the replay it'll be
it should come out automatically not by
me but by the company that hosts the
webinar
so you know sign up the link will be in
below in the description and you know if
you're interested in orderflow and
General visit my website orderflows
docomo a lot of these videos you know
people say oh you're neglecting your
blog but you know there's only so much
time in the day you know I I find it's
it's I can talk a lot faster than I can
type and you know until I hire an
assistant to transcribe everything I say
and put it into a blog post um you know
this will have to do for now so thanks
and again I hope to see you on my
webinar tomorrow bye-bye